[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء في حصاد الليله
معكم حسن جموله في الوقت الذي يكون فيه
تقع واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى
هذه مدينه اعزاز في ريف حلب الشماليه
وعايده سقوط قتل وجرحى في قصف لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في وقت يسود فيه
الترقب لعمليه بريه تركيه ضد الجماعات
الكرديه الشماليه سوريا
اما هذه صور ستاتينا من طهران اثر اعلانها
اجراءات من بينها وتسريع تفصيل اليورانيوم
في منشات فورد ردا على قرار من مجلس
محافظين الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
في تاكيد على هجوم بري مرتقب في شمال
السوري اردوغان يقول ان تركيا ستهاجم ما
وصفها بمواقع الارهابيين بدبابات وجنون
المدفعيه التركيه تقصف مواقع ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه واهدافا اخرى
وتنتج يحذر من تهديد مهمه الحاق الهزيمه
بتنظيم الدوله وموسكو تدعو تركيا الى ضبط
النفس
بعد اجينا من الانتقادات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه ايران تبدا تفصيل
اليورانيوم لدرجه نقاء 60 في المئه في
موقع فوردو وتضخ الغاز في اجهزه طرد
مركزيه متطوره بريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا
تندد والبيت الابيض يشدد لن نسمح لايران
بامتلاك سلاح النووي وجميع الخيارات متاحه
للرئيس
في ختام جلسات الحوار الاستراتيجي في
الدوحه بين الولايات المتحده ودوله قطر
وزير الخارجيه القطريه يقول ان المباحثات
شملت تطورات الملف النووي الايرانيه
وقضايا العراق وليبيا وافغانستان وفلسطين
وبنينكم يؤكد اهميه الشراكه بين واشنطن
والدوحه لحل الخلافات وانهاء الصراعات
الاقليميه والدوليه
مشاهدينا في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد
على منصاتنا الرقميه
نقشنا الامال والاجواء التي انعاشها
انتصار السعوديه تاريخيه على الارجنتين
بهدفين مقابل هدف واحد في مونديال قطر
2022 وهو فوزي اعتبر من كبر المفاجات في
تاريخ كاس العالم لكره القدم لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما هي فرص
السعوديه للتاهل للدور الثاني بعد فوزها
اللافتات على الارجنتين وقد جاءت النتيجه
على النحو التالي
نحو 59% قالوا ان الفرصه كبيره في حين قال
ثلاثه وثلاثون في المئه ان هناك فرص
معقوله بينما صوت ثمانيه في المائه بالقول
انه لا فرصه لتاهل السعوديه للدور الثاني
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصه الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وانا نتطرى خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
مشاهدينا وبعد الحصاد مباشره و تحديدا في
الساعه الثانيه وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه
يوميات المونديال التي ترصد بالخدر
والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر 20022
[موسيقى]
كنا نهاجم الارهابيين على مدار ايام قليله
بطائرتنا ومدافعنا وبنادقنا ان شاء الله
سنقتلهم جميعا في اسرع وقت ممكن باستخدام
دباباتنا وجنودنا هذا ما جاء في نص كلمه
القاها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
شمال شرقي تركيا
الهجوم البري في شمال سوريا قادم اذا خلال
ايام وربما سعد
هجوم مرتقب دفع واشنطن للتحذير من التاثير
على محاربه تنظيم الدوله بينما دعت موسكو
انقره الى ضبط النفس
قصاص واكثر كان القصد في البدر الانتقام
لضحايا تفجير اسطنبول الاخير لكنه
الواسعه على مواقع لفصائل كليه المسلحه في
شمال سوريا والعراق قد تتسع رقعتها
بالتصريح والتلميح معا تنبئك انقره بان
العمليه البريه قادمه لا محاله
من هذه اللحظه
وهدفا واحدا وهو تحقيق امني مواطنين
ودولتنا انه حق شرعي لنا ان نذهب للنقطه
والمنطقه التي يبدا امننا منها وعلى الدول
التي جاءت من مسافه الاف الكيلومترات
لتحقيق امنها باستخدام القوه المفرطه ان
تتفهم حقا الشرعيه هذا هناك خط رسمناه في
مناطق داخل العراق وسوريا لتحقيق امن
مواطنينها واذا تطلب الامر سحب هذا الخطي
والتغيير مكانه اكثر فاكثر فاننا مستعدون
لذلك
لا تخفي تركيا تدمرها من دعم دول لما
تعتبره هي منظمات ارهابيه تشير عن قرب ذلك
الى حزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه
الشعب الفصيل الابرز فيما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه
فيما يخص رؤوس فانه في نظر الاتراك غير
ملتزمين بالمساعده في تطهير المنطقه من
التهديد الارهابي وفقا للتفاق سوتشي قد لا
يفهم الكلام
بالطريقه نفسها غير انه يبدي تفهما لها
واجز انقره التي يصفها بالمشروعه بشان
ضمان امنها
الاطراف كافه الى ضبط النفس والابتعاد عن
الخطوات المتعزعه للاستقرار في جميع انحاء
سوريا
ولين الامريكيين هناك ايضا فاين الاتراك
حلفائهم في اليوتيوب يدعو لهم الى وقف
دعمهم لمقاتلين اكراد سوريين
واشنطن التي تقود التحالف الدولي الداعم
الرئيسيه لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قتاليا ضد تنظيم الدوله
ترفض اي عمل عسكري في سوريا او العراق
مع قوات التحالف الدولي بقياده الولايات
المتحده لكن القياده الوسطى للجيش
الامريكي
وقوع غاره على مواقع تستضيف قواتها قالت
ان الوحدات الامريكيه كانت في مناى من
الخطر
وقد قاده مناسب الشؤون الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
تركيا تعاني من تهديد الارهابي لاسيه مع
على حدودها الجنوبيه وان لديها الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسها
الدبلوماسيه لكن مصدر قلقنا بهذا الشان
ليس جديدا واود الاشاره اولا الى ان تركيا
لا تزال تعاني من تهديد ارهابي مشروع
ولاسيما في جنوبها وبالتاكيد لها كل الحق
في الدفاع عن نفسها وعن شعبها قلقنا بشان
العمليه العابره للحدود لا يزال نفسه وهو
انها قد تجبر شركائنا في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على اتخاذ رد فعل من شانه ان
يحد او يقيد قدرتهم على مواصلات القتال ضد
تنظيم الدوله وهذا ما نقوم به معه على
الارض
معنى من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد فايز
كيف يمكن توقع شكل وحجم العمليه العسكريه
البريه التركيه في شمال سوريا لو حصلت
يعني الان تم من يوم امس التحويل الامر
الى الخليه الاستراتيجيه او الخليه
العسكريه المعنيه بذلك التي عليها ان تضع
في حسبانها وعلى طاوله البحث
الموقف الامريكي والموقف الروسي قبل
اندلاع الحرب الاوكرانيه كان هناك تحضيرات
لشن عمليه ولكن تم الغائها لان كان هناك
معارضه واضحه روسيه امريكيه الان تحليل
الخطاب الروسي الامريكي
كلاهما يتحدث عن تعرض همم
تركيا الى اعمال ارهابيه وان لها الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسه اذا ما عرضنا ان نترجم هذا
هذه الجمل نقول كانها همم وضعت نفسها في
المنطقه الرماديه
وحاولت ان تترك لتركيا حيز من العمل هل
هذا الحيز سيسترد الى اتفاقيه حضرنا التي
تؤمن في احد بنودها السريه وقد تم الاشاره
اليها في اكثر من تقرير
خلو المنطقه من اي وجود مسلح ارهابي يقع
الى الشمال من طريق انفور وهذه الطريق
تقريبا في بعض المناطق عمقها 30 كلم من خط
الحدود السياسي الان ما هي المناطق
المرشحه للعمليه لانه هناك مناطق تعتبر
مناطق مزعجه تركيه اولا منه رفعت هذه
المشكله تكون في وجود قوات روسيه مليشيات
ايرانيه قوات النظام
المنطقه الثانيه منبج وهذه المشكله تكمن
في وجود قوات روسيه قوات امريكيه قوات
بريطانيه قوات فرنسيه المنطقه الثالثه عين
العرب كوباني يوجد قوات امريكيه قوات
فرنسيه قوات بريطانيا نذهب الان شرقا في
هذه المنطقه الى الحسكه والقامشلي هناك
تواجد روسي وتواجد امريكي اذا اتوقع ان
المخطط
يتجه سيختار احد هذه الاهداف الاربعه وقد
يختار اكثر من هدف ولكن يراعي الحضور
للقوات الاجنبيه بحيث لا يكون هناك احتكاك
او خطا في اداره المعركه يفضي الى ايقاع
خسائر فيها القوه
ان اتفاقيه اذنا ستكون الاساس في التوسع
اذا ما حدث ذلك
بوجود كل هذه القوات في النقاط التي تشكل
او في المناطق التي تشكل ازعاجا
لتركيا لكن لو اخذنا الجانب الروسي تحديدا
يعني ال- ال- الجانب الروسي اشار الى تفهم
لهواجز همم تركيا الامنيه ولكنه هو اعلن
بصراحه انه طالب انقر بعدم القيام بعمليه
عسكريه في شمال السوري
هل يمكن لتركيا هنا في ضوء هذا الموقف ان
تتجاهل هذا الامر وتدخل الى تلك المناطق
التي يشترك في الوجود فيها بمعظمها الروس
يعني الان الوجود الروسي تقريبا يتركز في
منطقه القامشلي وفي منبج
وهذه المناطق يمكن ان تتجنبها العمليات
العسكريه يعني الان المعارضه الروسيه
اعتقد من اجل ايجاد او فسحه مفاوضات روسيه
تركيه حول ادلب لماذا لانه هناك اتهام
روسي مقابل للجانب التركي انه لم يلتزم
باتفاقيه سوشي عسى تانا من حيث اخلاء كافه
النقاط وكافه
الفصائل الثوره التي تتواجد جنوب الانفار
في ادلب وهنا يجب ان نتحدث عن مدينه اريحا
عن جبل شعشبوه عن جبل الاربعين ولكن اعتقد
ان تركيا لن تقبل بهذه المقايضه لماذا
لانه سيكون هناك عمليه نزوح كبيره جدا
وتركيا
ومتخمه باللاجئين وادلب مدخمه باللاجين
لكن دعني اقول
تصريح الرئيس التركي واضح من حيث استخدام
القوه البريه القوه الرائعه وتركيا نفذت
اربعه عمليات لم تحظى بالرضا والقبول نفذ
الدرع الفرات نفذت غسل الزيتون نفذت نبع
السلام نفذ الدرع الربيع وبالتالي هي خضعت
او همم استجابت للمواقف الرافضه فيما قبل
الحرب الاوكرانيه الان الوضع مختلف الوضع
المحوري في جمله واحده الوضع المحوري
لتركيا الانفلف روسيا تخطب وجهها من اجل
الازمه الاوكرانيه امريكا تكتب بدها ومن
اجل مشكله الحبوب والعزم العقرانيه
وبالتالي كلاهما الان سيغظ الطرف ولو
جزئيا عن اي توجه
تركي لتنفيذ عمليه عسكريه بريه شكرا لك
لواء فايز الدويري يلا خضير العسكري
والاستراتيجي حدثتنا من عمان
العمليه العسكريه البريه التركيه المحتمله
ستسادف مناطق ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه التي يشكل المسلحون الاكراد
اغلبيه مقاتلينها عن هذه القوه كيف تشكلت
وما مدى ثقل وجودها على الاراضي السوريه
في التقرير الثاني
وهي احد اهم خصومه تركيا على ارض سوريا
خصوصا مع مشاهدته حدودها الجنوبيه اخيرا
من قصه هجمات فما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تصنف تركيا مكوناتها على انها
امتداد لحزب العمال الكردستاني المعروف
اختصارا لكيكي
ارهابيا تشكلت هذه القوات بمسماها الجديد
عام 2015 نواتها الرئيس مسلحون اكراد
ينطون تحت مسمى وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
وحدات حمايه المراه اضافه الى فصائل اخرى
تضم مقاتلين من ابناء المنطقه بدايه
الثوره السوريه عام 2011 كان وجوده وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه محدوده سيطره
والتسبيحدد في مناطق من محافظه الحسكه
وعين العرب كوباني واح
في مدينه حلب اضافه الى مدينه عفرين
ومحيطها الذي في حلب الغربي لاحقا توسع
وجود هذه القوات الشرق وغرب نهر الفرات
بعد تبني الولايات المتحده لها ودعمها في
المعارك ضد تنظيم الدوله كما تبدا وجود
نفس القوات الى مناطق كانت تحفظ سيطره
المعارضه السوريه المسلحه العمليه
العسكريه البريه التركيه المحتمله قد تنفذ
في اكثر من منطقه تصيطر عليها ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لكن المناطق
الحدوديه تبدو الاهم لانقره لابعاد
المسلحين الاكراد مع بقاء احتمال امتدادها
لمناطق في العمق السوريه سواء شرق نهر
الفرات او غربه
[موسيقى]
ايران تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه تصل الى 60%
القريبه من الدرجه اللازمه لصنع اسلحه
وذلك تحت الارض لاول مره في محطتها في
فردوس
لتوسيع التوصيلها في فردوس
اليوم من الوكاله الدوليه
على قرار صدر الخميس من الوكاله يحمل
انتقادات لايران بريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا
بخطه ايران لتوسيع برنامج التصيب والبيت
الابيض يقول ان كل الخيارات متاحه للرايس
من تحت الارض خذتهب طهران ما بقي من اوراق
على طاوله مفاوضات ملفها النووي تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 60 في المئه في مجمع
فردو يرفع نسبه التوتر اكثر بينها وبين
الوكالات الدوليه للطاقه الذريه واطراف
اتفاق ينفذ انفسه الاخيره بغضب كبير
استقبل الطهران قرار مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الذي يامرها بالتعاون بشكل عاجل مع تحقيق
يستمر منذ شهور ما يجري في فندق هو جزء من
الرد الايراني على قرار الخميس الماضي
بنظر المسؤولين الايراني الخطوه الاخيره
لم تكن مفاجاه للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص
لايران
طريقه عمل ايران عندما يعبر المجتمع
الدولي عن مخاوف حقيقيه بشان برنامجهم
النووي وعن انهم ليسوا شفافين وهم يردون
بالتصعيد
في رساله الاحتجاج التي بعثتها طهران
للوكاله ورد انها ستفعل سلسله جديده من
اجهزه الطرد المركزي في فورد
بموجب اتفاق 2015 وافقت على وقف العمل في
الفندق وعدم التجاوز عتبه ثلاثه فاصل 67
في المئه لتخصيب اليورانيوم بين ان انسحاب
اداره الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب منه دفعها الى التخلي التدريجيا عن
التزاماتها كما توضح جهود الاداره الحاليه
لاحياء الاتفاق وصلت الى طريق مسدود
المفاوضات المجمده منتصب تنبر الماضي رغم
اعتقادي وزير الخارجيه لامريكي ان الامل
ضئيل فيها الحاله الامور بسبب الاحتجاجات
في ايران الا انه يترك باب الحوار مفتوحا
كما قلنا من قبل واكثر من مره ما زلنا
نؤمن ان افضل وسيله لتجاوز تحديات برنامج
ايران النووي هي الدبلوماسيه ايران
والاسباب متعدده اختارت اقامه قضايا
خارجيه في جهود احياء الاتفاق النووي مع
القوى العالميه
تازمت العلاقه بين طهران والوكاله الدوليه
بعد عصور المفتشين على اثار اليورانيوم في
ثلاثه مواقع غير معلنه وبدا بعدها مسلسل
التقارير والتقارير المضاده بينهما الثابت
فيها اسرار الوكاله على عدم الحصول على
اجابات واضحه وفقدان التعاون المطلوبي
للتحقيق في الامر
يورانيوم فرض العالم النقاء سيخفض نسب اي
تقارب هذه الفتره جمع الوكاله في فيينا بل
القوه الغربيه المعنيه باتفاق النوويه لم
يبقى منه سوا
معنى من مدينه كامبردج بولايه مساجد
غاريسي مورس منسق البيت الابيض لشؤون
المناعه انتشار اسلحه الدمار الشامل في
عهد الرئيس اوباما ومن طهران معانا عباس
اصلااني الباحث في مركز الشرق الاوسط
للدراسات
[موسيقى]
يعني عندما تقوم ايران برفع مستوى تصيب في
محطتين فردو
ونطنز الى نسبه 60%
الى اين تريد ان تصل ماذا تريد ان تقول
وسبق انهدت بنفس الاسلوب من دون ان يؤدي
الامر الى اي نتيجه ايجابيه لها
في الوقت الذي لا نرى فيه
اي قرارين وواضح من الولايات المتحده هذا
كانت لرد من ايران ان تحاول تصعيد نشاطتها
النوويه حجه ايران انه كانت نهائيه ضغطا
من الطرف الاخر لان
تكلفها اكثر وسترد ايران على ذلك كما
تعرفون في الوقت المفاوضات التي حصلت في
الاسابيع الماضيه فيينا وقبل انتهاء تلك
النقاشات كانت مسوده القرار قد تم تهيئتها
في وقت سابق وكان هذا يعتمد على ما سيحدث
في ايران والتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه اطراف الغربيه تريد ان تضع
قرارا وتصدره من اجل ان تضغط على طهران
ولهذا فان طاهران تقول ان الاطراف الغربيه
تحاول ان تسيس جزء منظمه فنيه متمثله
بالوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بالتالي
ايران ردت على ما تسمى هذه الاجراءات غير
البناء من حول نشاطات النوويه وتريد ايران
ان تضعها ضغط على الطرف الاخر من اجل ان
توقف هذه الاجراءات وان تعود الى طاوله
المفاوضات من اجل التفاوض التواصل الى
اتفاق لم تجيبني على السؤال
المحدد واضح ان هذا هو رد من ايران على
مصادر عن الوكاله لكن السؤال
60% وصلت الى الان نسبه او مستوى التخصيب
هل يمكن في ما لو لم تتجاوب الوكاله ولم
تستنى في المفاوضات ان تذهب ايران نحو
فعلا ال 90%
اييي انتاج اسلحه نبويه هل هذا ممكن في
اطار الضغط ايضا
ايران ستسعى
للقيام
بالسعي للحصول على سلاح النووي ان السياسه
الايرانيه الواضحه كانت كذلك كانت واضحه
في عدم رغبتها بالحصول على سلاح كيف
ستستمر ايران بردود الفعل اذا ما كان
هنالك اجراءات اضافيه من الاطراف الغربيه
الامر سي- سيميدو على نوعيه همم تلك
الضغوط المفروض على ايران اعتقد انه سيكون
هنالك اجراءات مختلفه مطروحه على الطاوله
من الجانب الايراني والامر سيعتمد على
الاجراءات التي
ستقوم بها الاطراف الغربيه
ان تشكل ردا مماثلا ومشابه لهذه الاجراءات
هذا هذه الردود ستعتمد على ما تقوم به
الاطراف الغربيه لكن لحد الان لم نسمع اي
شيء من المسؤولين الايرانيين حول مسائيه
بنسبه 90% لكن في علينا ان ننتظر
لنعرف ما الذي سيحدث مستقبلا وسنعرف ردود
الغرب بعد ذلك بامكاننا نوعا ما ان همم
نتنبا بما ستقوم به الى المستقبل وكما قلت
هذا الامر يعتمد على الطرف الاخر بالفعل
علينا ان همم ان نعرف ما هي ردود الغرب
وهذا ما سال عنه السيد جاري سيمور ما هي
الخيارات المطروحه امام الغرب امام
الولايات المتحده والبيت الابيض يقول كل
الخيارات امام الرئيس
على الطاوله
وانا الولايات المتحده لديها خيارات
محدوده في حقيقه الامر من الواضح ان
الرئيس بيدا لا يريد ان يشل عمليه عسكريه
ضد ايران وانا اعتقد ان ايران كانت حظيره
للغايه من اجل ان تتفادى نسبه التقصير 90%
التي تمكنها من الحصول على سلاح و اعتقدوا
انها من الممكن ان تطلق عمليه ازمه عسكريه
بين الغرب وايران لذلك في الوقت الحالي
الطرفان يستمراني انهم مهتمون بالمفاوضات
لكن بصراحه ليس هنالك اي تقدم تم احرازه
بالنسبه للمفاوضات الوكاله الدوليه الى
طاقه الدلاليه وايران قد عقدها الكثير من
المحادثات والنقاشات من اجل حل القضايا
التي والاسئله التي اثارتها الوكاله
الدوليه في السابق حول النشاطات النوويه
سابقه في ايران ولم يتم احراز تقدم
الاتفاق
لحياء همم
همم الاتفاق النووي الذي تم ابرامه في عام
2015 هذا الاتفاق تم انتهى في اغسطس لكن
في لحظات الاخيره تراجعت ايران وقد تقدمت
بمطالب جديده وهذا الامر لم يكن مقبولا
للولايات المتحده وللقوى الاوروبيه لذلك
الحاليه ليس هنالك اي تطور الدبلوماسيه تم
احرازه وبصراحه الطرفان الان مشتتان
بقضايا اخرى كلا لبن ايران والدول الغربيه
تركزوا على مساله الاحتجاجات التي تحصل في
ايران وايضا على الدعم ايران وتجهيزها
للاسلحه لروسيا كجزء من هذه الحرب
المستمره في اوكرانيا وايضا القضيه
النوويه لم تحضر اهتماما كبير
[موسيقى]
وصول التفصيل الى مستوى 60% في منشئتي
فرده اي ضغط يمكن ان يشكله ذلك على
الوكاله الدوليه
الذريه هذا ما تامل ايران وايضا على دول
الغربيه بشكل عام من اجل العوده الى
التفاوض هل هذه وسيله الضغط يمكن ان تنجح
سواء باي شكل اساسي ايران تهدد باتخاذ
خطوات اضافيه من اجل توسيع نشاطاتها
النوويه اذا ما قام مجلس همم مجلس
المحافظين الوكاله بتمريري القرار ضد
ايران وبشكل النهائي اذا ما قام ذلك
المجلس في حاله ايران الى مجلس الامن
الدولي من اجل اجراءات الاضافيه انا اعتقد
ان
الاوروبيين
والولايات المتحده تريد ان تتفادى
المواجهه لكن في نفس الوقت اذا ما لم يكن
هنالك اي يتقدم يتم احرازه على حول القضيه
بين الوكاله الدوليه وايران ففي نهايه
المطاف سيكون هناك رفع تقرير واحاله ايران
الى مجلس الامن هو يكون هناك تصويت
بالاجماع بالتاكيد مجلس الامن لاني اخذ
قرار لان روسيا والصين باعاقته اي قرار
لفرض عقوبات على
لكن ايران مره اخرى
سنفترض انها سيكون لها الرد على اجراءات
الوكاله وهذا قد يتضمن التخصيب الى 90%
لكنني كما قلت ان هذا الامر
سيسبب ازمه امم عسكريه قد تحصل وهذا امر
لا ترغب بحصوله ايران ولا الولايات
المتحده لكن يبدو وكاننا نتجه نحو جهه
سلبيه في تطور الامور
في عهد الرئيس اوباما شكرا جزيلا لكم شكرا
لعباس اصلا هي البحث في مركز الشرق الاوسط
للدراسات كان معنا من طهران
مشاهدينا لاحقا في فكره المتابعه مرصود
انتقادات الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
وتفاصيل الرد الايراني ونسال ضيف الحصاد
عن افاق الازمه تصعيد ام سبل وتهدئه
[موسيقى]
الى العاصمه القطريه الدوحه حيث وقع وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي اليوم مع نادي برئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الرحمن الثاني اعلان خطاب بشان
التعاون الثنائي في القضايا المتعلقه
باستضافه كاس العالم وذلك على هامش الحوار
الاستراتيجي الخامس بين الولايات المتحده
وقطر وسيمكن هذا الاعلان البلدين من تبادل
المعارف بشان الاستعداد الاستضافه بطوله
كاس العالم كما سيعل جانبان الى البناء
على التقدم الذي تم احرازه في كاس العالم
2022 لتعزيز امكانيه الوصول بشكل اكبر
للمشجعين ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه لحضور
المباريات
وكان امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال
ثاني قد استعرض مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلنكن العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين واوجهها تعزيزها
في مختلف المجالات حسب ما جاء في تغريده
للديوان الاميري القطري اوضح فيها ان
اللقاء عقد في استاد احمد بن علي في
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه
قال الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني نائب
رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
ان الحوار الاستراتيجيه السنوي بين الدوحه
واشنطن منصه مهمه في العلاقه بين البلدين
وخلال المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك مع نظيره
الامريكي قال وزير الخارجيه القطري ان
هناك مع نظيره الامريكي تطورات الاتفاق
النووي الايراني والاوضاع في العراق
وليبيا وافغانستان والقضيه الفلسطينيه
فرصه اليوم لاقامه الجوله الخامسه من
الحوار الاستراتيجي القطري الامريكي والذي
يعتبره بنصحاب في تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه
بين بلدين التي تتمت
باسس قويه وصلبه وشراكه متعدده الاوجه
وتعتبر من اهم شركات الاستراتيجيه لدوله
قطر طبعا الشراكه تمتد
الشراكه السياسيه وفي مجال الدفاع والحب
وفي زراعه الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه همم كان اليوم الذي الى فرصه
لمناقشه قضايا متعدده سواء اركان على همم
ما يخص القضايا الاقليميه وايضا التحديات
التي يواجهها العالم اليوم همم كان على
ااا اجدده اجتماعاتنا مناقشه تطورات طبعا
ااا الاتفاق النووي الايراني وايضا
التطورات في الساحه العراقيه
ولبدان وليبيا وايضا القضيه الفلسطينيه
التي تعتبر القضيه المركزيه لدينا
كما قال لنا ابو رئيسي مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني ان تنظيم كاس العالم لم
يكن سببا وراء الاصلاحات التي حدثت في قطر
اخيرا هل هو محفز لها واضاف ان عمليه
الاصلاح عمليه مستمره وغير مرتبطه بحدث
معين وتعكس رؤيه القياده في الدوله
للتغيير ومواكبه المتغيرات في العالم
بالنسبه لمساله الاصلاحات التي
حدثت في السنوات الاخيره
الكثير قد يعتقد ان كاس العالم هو سبب
الرئيسي لهذه الاصلاحات ولكن
نحن نرى ان كاس العالم هو فقط محفز
لهذا الشيء ومسرع للعمليه بينبا هناك رؤيه
اعلى قياده
لرؤيه سمو الامير حفظه الله هي رؤيه تحول
لدوله قطر ومواكب المتغيرات التي تحدث في
العالم حولنا وهذه عمليه مستمره وغير همم
بمقاطع ولا ترتبط بحدث معين
من جهه هناء وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطونيو بلانكين دوله قطر على تنظيم كاس
العالم واكد ان خطاب امير قطر الشيخ تميم
بن حمد الثاني خلال حفل الافتتاح رساله
مهمه لتعزيز مبدا الشموليه التي يمثلها
هذا الحدث الكروي العالمي وجعلها واقعا
وفي مؤتمر صحفي مشترك في الدوله القطريه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني اسند
لانكن على العمل الكبير الذي قدمته قطر
لتنظيم كاس العالم وقال انها حققت خطوات
وصفها بالمهمه في السنوات الاخيره لتحسين
قوانين العمل وتوسيعه حقوق العمال مؤكدا
ان واشنطن كانت وستبقى شريكا ملتزما في
تلك الجيوب
انا
اول بطوله لكاس العالم في الشرق الاوسط
انه خطاب الامير الذي رحب فيه بجميع هنا
لحضور كاس العالم رساله مهمه لحدث يجمع
الناس من كل الخلفيات والامم والديانات
والميول الجنسيه
الولايات المتحده وقطر شراكه ثنائيه
واقليميه ابحث عالميه اكثر فاكثر في
مجالات متعدده وكشفا يمكن انه ناقشه مع
الجانب القطري توسيع هذه الشراكه لتشمل
جهود تنسيق جهود الاغاثه الدوليه وتقديم
مساعدات انسانيه لمنهم في حاجه اليها
لعبه الاسبوع
وعالميه اكثر فاكثر وقت شهدنا ذلك خلال
الشهور والسنوات الاخيره في اماكن متنوعه
التعامل الذي ذكرته بشان افغانستان
الولايات المتحده طبعا استضافه القوه
قطر
بشان اوكرانيا
الحاجات الدوليه من الطاقه وهناك ايضا
العديد من المجالات التي نعمل فيها بالشكل
الوفيق والتي لقطر فيها تاثير مهم الشيء
الاخر الذي يناقشناه اليوم واعتقد انه مهم
والعمل الذين يقوموا به وامنوا ان ننسق
بشكل اكبر جهودنا لتقديم الاغاثه
والمساعده الانسانيه لمنهم في حاجه اليها
وفي تغريده على موقع تويتر تزالنت مع
لقاءاته التي عقدها في الدوحه قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
ان الحوار الاستراتيجيه مع قطر هذا العام
دليل على شراكه القويه التي تجمع البلدين
وانه سيعزز تعاونهما المشترك في مجموعه من
القضايا الثنائيه والاقليميه والعالميه
وفقه تعبير
وعليها مش الحوار الاستراتيجيه الخامس بين
الولايات المتحده وقطر قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه القطريه ماجد الانصاري للجزيره
ان اعلان خطاب النيات بين البلدين ياتي
لدعم التعاون الثنائي في القضايا المتعلقه
بتجربه استضافه كاس العالم واوضح ان هذا
الاعلان سيمكن البلدين من تبادل المعارف
بشان الاستعداد لاستضافه بطوله كاس العالم
عام 2026
خطاب نوايا الذي وقع عليها اليوم بين قطر
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو يتضمن
حقيقه اتفاق المبدئيا اييه يقضي بتشكيل
مجموعه عمل لتطبيق ما تم الاتفاق عليه في
هذا الخطاب حول امكانيه تبادل التجارب
فيما يتعلق باستضافه كاس العالم والتجربه
استضافه كاس العالم سواء في قضايا
التنظيميه والقضايا الامنيه وتذكره
المتعلقه
بحمايه بحقوق الانسان والعماله حيث انا
طبعا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي احد
الدول التي تستضيف النسخه القادمه من كاس
العالم قطر مستضيفه النسخه الحاليه
وقال الانصاري للجزيره انه تمت مناقشه
وقضايا العراق وليبيا وافغانستان والقضيه
الفلسطينيه والتطورات الملف النووي
الايرانيه واضح ان دوله قطر تدعم العوده
للاتفاق النووي وانها ملتزمه بمواصله فتح
قنوات الاتصال مع كافه الاطراف المعنيه
لتدليل اي عقبات او تحديات تقف امام
الاتفاق
هناك
التوصل اليه الى الان اولاويات المرحله
القادمه وكذلك التحديات لان نشات من
التطورات الاخيره في هذا الملف سواء على
صعيد العلاقه مع بين ايران متحده
الامريكيه والاطراف الغربيه او بتطورات
الاقليميه والدوليه التي تحيط بايران في
هذه المنطقه في العالم طبعا قطر ما زالت
كما كانت دائما هي دائما للوصول الى اتفاق
يقضي بالعوده الى همم اتفاق انه لعام 2015
وقد قامت قطر سابقا بجهود مختلفه في
ايطاليا دعم الوسيط
الاوربيه
جلسات حوار غير مباشره هنا في في الدوحه
ومزرت قطر ملتزمه بهذا الدوله
معنى من ميريلاند هو روبن نائب مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق مرحبا بك سيد
روبن اييي ماذا يعني استمرار وتواصل
للحوار الاستراتيجي بين دوله قطر
والولايات المتحده في سياق
العلاقات التي تجمع البلدين
الذي يحصل الان ليس فقط خلال
كاس العالم على انهن قطر لتنظيم هذا الحدث
المهم وهي تقدم قطر بطريقه رائعه للعالم
هذا هو الحوار الاستراتيجي الخامس وهذا
يعني ان العلاقه عميقه وقويه وكما سمعنا
من تعليقات لوزير لين كنا هي متنوعه تغطي
الجوانب الاقتصاديه والعلاقات العسكريه
والسياسيه ايضا هو ايضا القضايات مثل
التعليم وانا اعرف ايضا ان قطر لديها
تعليم مبادرات تعليم مهمه عالميه هذه هي
العلاقات العميقه التي نراها الان امام
نتيجه العمل المكثف الذي حصل بين قطر
والولايات المتحده منذ سنوات وانا متاكد
ان هذه العلاقه عميقه ستنمو ستستمر
مستقبلا ما هي العوامل التي همم اوصلت الى
هذا المستوى من العلاقات العميقه بين
الولايه المتحده ودوله قطر
الاساس في حقيقه الامر كان هنالك الاحساس
المشترك
للاهميه الاستراتيجيه والقيم الاستراتيجيه
الاعتراف مثلا بان
موجود
قاعده العديده الامريكيه في قطر هذا يعكس
ان الولايات المتحده لديها
احتياجات ومصالح امنيه في الخليج وايضا
الولايات المتحده تدعم قطر عالميا في تدعم
العلاقات التجاريه هذه هي الاسس التي
راينا على اساسها هذه العلاقه تنمو وتتطور
وهذا الحوار الاستراتيجي بين الوزيرين كان
حوارا ورديا وصريحا وهمم واعتقد في عمل
اداره
هذه هي ال- هذا هو الاجواء التي نراها
تسود العلاقات وعلى المستوى الرسميه ايضا
وايضا خلال السنه الماضيه على اثري في
افغانستان عندما لاعبه قطر دوله اسيا
مساعده الولايات المتحده في اخراج الناس
المواطنين الامريكيين من افغانستان
ومستقديم الدعم اعتقدوا ان كان له تاثير
كبير في الجانب التنفيذي وفي وزاره
الخارجيه ووزاره الدفاع كان له صدى ايجابي
وانا ارى ان هذه التعاون سيستمر بطريقه
اكبر مستقبلا
ان مذكره او توقيع مذكره التفاهم التي
تعنى بتبادل المعارف بشان تنظيم كاس
العالم همم
2026 كيف تنظر الولايات المتحده الى مستوى
التنظيم الذي همم بدا في كاس العالم في
دوله قطر
كما تعرفون من كان من الرائع مراقبه ما
حصل قطر بلد صغير ولكي تتمكن ان تستضيف
مثل هذا الحدث المهمه
واعتدوا انه كان نتيجه عمل مكثف لسنوات
بسطاعتنا ان نتعلم الكثير من القدر في
مساله التخطيط والتنظيم اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده كونها البلد النظيفه القادم بهذا
الامور بامكانها ان تنفعنا وايضا الخبرات
الامنيه الدروس المستفاده هذه هذا ليس
حدثا يسهل وتنظيمه واعتقد ان
المخططين الامريكيين سيهتمون في العمل
ويكتسبوا الخبرات التي
تستبدتها قطر من تنظيمها هذا الحدث المهم
جو ال- روبن من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك نائب مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي السابق كنت معنا من
ميريلاند
[موسيقى]
مدينه
سيارتين كانت تهاجمان المدينه
طياره وفقا للمعلومات الاوليه مؤكدا ان
جميع القوات والخدمات في حاله تاهب وان
ايام من المنشات المدنيه لم تصب
كانت مباراه تمثل مفاجاه بكل ما فيها بكل
تفاصيلها
اوكي استاذ
الرياض
كما شاهدنا ولكن هذه المباراه كانت مباراه
حماسيه للغايه تابعها
مشجعوا الارجنتين هنا وسط العاصمه
الارجنتينيه وين هسه لدينا ايضا احد
المشجعين من السعوديه الذين يقيمون هنا في
الارجنتين ما هو شعورك بعد هذه المباراه
التي شاهدتها الان شعور جميل وسط
الارجنتينيين الان وبين كل هذا الشعب
والجمع والحماس اللي قاعدين يشوفوا الان
السعوديه تمتصر وانا موجود هنا بين
الارجنتين
شيء للامانه مفاجئ للامانه لنا في
كمونديال ان السعوديه تفوز على الارجنتين
ما كان عندي توقع ان السعوديه ممكن تسجل
هدف واحد ولكن اللي حصل مفاجاه جميله
وانتصار صراحه يسجل يا تاريخ سجل يا تاريخ
في وسط يونس ايرس شكرا جزيلا اذا هذه هي
الاجواء
هنا بعد هذا
الحال ما يقال عنه انه حدث تاريخي مع
بدايه كاس العالم قطر 2002 2020 ونحن
ننتظر بقيه مباريات هذا المونديال الذي
على ما يبدو انه يحمل المزيد من المفاجاه
حسن مسعود الجزيره وين صايرس
وفي المجموعه الرابعه السهله المنتخب
التونسي مشاركته في كاس العالم قطر 2022
بتعادل سلبي لكنه بطعم الفوز امام نظيره
الدنماركيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا العوده الى الجدل المتعلق
ببرنامج ايران النووي تقرير من الوكاله
ورد فعل للظلام
2015 بين ايران والدول الكبرى لكن
العلاقات بين الوكاله الامميه والطيران
تراجعت بشكل كبير في الاشهر الاخيره تمارس
الوكاله الامميه ضغوطا على ايران للحصول
منها على اجوبته بشان الوجود مواد نوويه
في ثلاثه مواقع غير معلنه بطبيعه الحال
هذه المساله الشائكه ادت الى صدور قرار من
مجلس حكام الوكاله عقد في حزيران يونيو
ينتقد ما يعتبره عدم تعاون من جانب ايران
وفي تقرير طلعت عليه وكاله فرانسبريس في
وقت سابقا من هذا الشهر ده فتره الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه الى ان مخزون ايران
من اليورانيوم المخصب تجاوز ثلاثه الاف
اهلا و70 كلغ من بحلوله 22 من اكتوبر
الماضي وذلك بانخفاض بلغ 2007 267 كغم و
200 غرام عن التقرير الفصلي الاخير يشمل
هذا المخزون
386.4 كغم من اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 20%
و62.3 كلغ من
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 60%
يوم الخميس الماضي مجلس حكام الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه تبنى قرارا ينتقد
ايران ويتهمها بعدم التعاون وذلك تسبب في
غضب طهران التي اعلنت اليوم اتخاذه
اجراءات عده ردا على قرار الوكاله ما هي
هذه الاجراءات
لاول مره بدات ايران انتاج اليورانيوم
المخصب بنسبه 60% في مجمع فوردو النووي
وهو ما يعد خطوه مهمه نحو مستوى التفصيل
بنسبه 90% هذا المستوى هو اللازم لانتاج
قنبله ذريه
بموجب اتفاق عام 2015 كانت ايران قد وافقت
على وقت تشغيل مجمع فردوه والحد من
تفصيبها لليورانيوم الى مستوى
3.67
لمعظم الاستخدامات
المدنيه نشير الى ان مجمع فرده بني تحت
الارض في محاوله لحمايته من اي ضربات جويه
او صاروخيه محتمله من قبل اعدائه
في كانونه ثانيه يناير 2021 اعلنت ايران
بدا تفصيل اليورانيوم بنسبه 20% في مجمعي
فردو وفي نيسان ابريل من العامزاته اعلنت
بدات تصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 60 بالمئه في
مجمع طنز في
الوسط كما
اعلن في طهران اليوم ان منظمه الطاقه
الذريه قامت بخطوه ثانيه باعاده النظر في
سلسلتين من اجهزه الطرب المركزي من طرازيه
عفوا اي ار تو ام او اي اي ار 4 في موقع
الغاز
من مدينه ليز في انجلترا الدكتور
علم صالح استاذ دراسات ايران والشرق
الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه
مرحبا بك دكتور صالح هذه التطورات التي
تبعناها بالتفصيل الى اين يمكن ان تصل
بالعلاقه بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
وخلف ذلك بين ايران ودول الغرب
الضغط امام الضغط والتصعيد امام التصعيد
هي السياسه
للتفاوضيه التي تتخذها طهران حاليا اتجاه
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وايضا ال
ال القوات الغربيه ومنها الامريكان
فلذلك ايران تعرف ان ليست لديها اوراق
متساويه كثيره مع عدا التصعيد الوضع او
تطور
النشاط النوويه هذه خاصه تاتي في في ظل
التصعيد او الضغوط الغربيه النوويه اتجاه
ايران وايضا واتجاه نشاطات النوويه
الايرانيه وايضا همم علاقات مع روسيا خاصه
في حرب اوكرانيا وايضا تصرفات ايران في
المنطقه فلذلك نرى ان هذا التصعيدات تاتي
ضد التصيدات همم اللي تاتي من غرب امام
ايران خاصه
همم القرار اللي صدرت من قبل مجلس محافظ
الوكاله همم الذريه فلذلك ايران همم تريد
ان تقول للغرب ان ان اردت ان تضبطوا فلذلك
انا ايضا اطور همم تخصيب الايراني
الضغوط والضغوط همم المقابله الى اي مستوى
يمكن ان تصل ايران ترفع الى 60% الوكاله
همم يعني تصاعد من لهجتها والغرب
والولايات المتحده ربما يزيد من العقوبات
يذهب الملف الى مجلس الامن وهو ما تحذر
منه ايران ماذا تفعل ايران بعد ذلك ترفع
الى 90% مثلا يعني ما هي الخيارات
المطروحه امام او اقصى خيار مطروح
ايران تعتقد ان هذه الضغوطات هي ضغوطات
سياسيه وليست تقنيه ولا ولا تربطها شيء
بنشاطات النوويه ان كانت اربعه% او 60% من
التقصير باليورانيوم ايران تعتقد ان هنالك
هجوم سياسي امني عسكري ضد ايران خاصه في
ظل
الاوضاع المتداوله داخليا حاليا فلذلك
ايران كانت لديها كميه تكفيها لصنع قنبله
نوويه همم قبل هذا قبل اسبوع ولكن الان
تريد ان تطوروا هذا اكثر همم فلذلك لكي
تضغط على الغرب حتى يتراجعوا من مطالباتهم
وهذه المطالبات تاتي في همم في عندما مجلس
محافظ الوكاله همم طلبوا من ايران
الشفافيه حول منشاتها النوويه الثلاثه
اللي كان فيها الشبهات حول تقسيم يعني يوم
بالصوره سريه همم فلذلك ايران تريد ان تحل
المشكله بصوره همم
لكن يبقى سؤال ماذا لو لم يتجاوب الطرف
الاخر مع هذه الضغوطات يعني ايضا الطرف
الاخر ما هي البدائل لديك
حاليا هي خطوه امام خطوه ايران لديها
خطوات اا اكثر من هذا ان ان تقطع علاقتها
مع الوكاله همم الذريه حول مراقبات
المنشات النوويه والكاميرات المراقبه ايضا
هناك بعض التعاون بين بين طهران والوكاله
طيران تستطيع في خطوه اخرى همم ان لم
يتنازل للقرض عن طلباتها ايضا تقطع كل
علاقاتها حول هذه الامور وايضا طبعا
الخطوه الاخيره تكون تقسيم الايرانيوم الى
نسبه 90% اللي هي تكفيه لصنع القنبله خلال
ايام همم ايران تعتقد ان لن تكون هنالك
خيار وحرب لامريكا ضد ايران فلذلك تريد ان
تقول له واشنطن المجلس
ونتفاوض ونحل المشكله من خلال السياسه
والدبلوماسيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه ليتس في انجلترا
الدكتور على مصالح استاذ دراسات ايران
بالشرق الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه
الاستراليه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل راس السنه بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
وهذا استعراض لاهم الانباء قبل الانتقال
الى الجوله الرياضيه يوميات المونديال
على واقع غارات تركيه متصاعده على مواقع
ما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في شمالي
سوريا
رجب طيب اردوغان بهجوم بريه قائلا ان
بلاده ستهاجم ما وصفها بمواقع الارهابيين
بدبابات وجنون
وافدت مصادر في شمال سوريا
الديمقراطيه جراء قصف تركيا على الثلج
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان الاعمال
العسكريه في شمال سوريا تهدد مهمه الحاق
الهزيمه بتنظيم الدوله وقال مناسب
للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان لدى تركيا الحلقه في
الدفاع عن نفسي لكنه اعرب عن خشيته من
تقويض القدره على قتال تنظيم الدوله
انقر الى ضبط النفس ولفتها الى انه يتفهم
واجلس تركيا بشان ضمان امنها وحسن المبعوث
الروسي الى سوريا الحكومه التركيه على عدم
استخدام القوه المفرطه في سوريا
اعلنت ايران بدا تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
60 بالمئه في منشاه فردو وقالت السلطات
الايرانيه انها ستضخ الغاز في اجهزه طرد
مركزيه جديده جاء ذلك بعد انتقادات
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وقد دانت
فرنسا وبريطانيا في بيان مشترك توسع
برنامج ايران النووي واعلن البيت الابيض
انه لن يسمح لايران بامتلاك سلاح النووي
لافتا الى ان جميع الخيارات تبقى متاحه
وقع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه مع نائب رئيس
مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني اعلان خطابيات
بشان التعاون الثنائيه وذلك على همش
الحوار الاستراتيجي الخامس بين البلدين
وقال وزير الخارجيه القطري ان المباحثات
شملت الملف النوويه الايراني وقضايا
العراق وليبيا وفلسطين وافغانستان
اهميه الشراكه بين واشنطن والدوحه لحل
الخلافات وانهاء الصراعات الاقليميه
والدولي
ختام الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]